hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and it's uh what is it it's Wednesday
September 28th uh 2022 and you know the
big market today was uh gold right I
mean you know there's there's many other
markets out there for Traders to look at
besides NASDAQ mnq and uh e-minis and
and micro e-mini's that uh follow order
flow in my opinion
better than you know equities because
you know commodity markets such as gold
um you know are driven more by supply
and demand factors and obviously there's
outside factors as well but you know
generally the day-to-day activity of
commodity markets follow order flow
better than
um these cash settled financial markets
and again sort of going back to who uses
and who trades these markets these
commodity markets you know its producers
its end users people that need to buy it
for a certain reason and that's why in
my opinion it follows spy and demand
better than some of these crazy Equity
markets where you know you have a lot of
hot money coming in and out of the
market so gold today you know I had a
very very strong move up I mean we had
this big move up from you know basically
1625 up to right now we're trading
around 1670. so you know it's almost a
50 move that's what 45 bucks but what
was the signs in the order flow and
again you know I do keep an eye on gold
I don't actively trade it but you know
it's a market that I like to watch
because again it's one of those markets
that other markets can tend to follow
and this morning in the gold I know you
know I watch a one minute chart on gold
and I know what the volumes are you know
on a footprint is considered heavy you
know 100 contracts at a price either on
the bid or the offer in my opinion is is
very strong volume now this morning
around five o'clock right we popped up
we had a nice uh basically Eight dollar
move actually a little bit more it's
about a ten dollar move over two minutes
you know from 23 and a half up to 33.
we had that big bar here that's on this
one minute chart you know it's from 25
up to 33. so about an eight dollar move
and then what happened is we retraced
all the way back okay fine
moves happen very quickly and what you
want to watch you know with the order
flow is if you retrace it or not right
is it going to continue or is it going
to pull back because what you want to
see is you know is that initial buying
that initial pump up is it still going
to be there right I mean for whatever
reason the market pumped then it came
off and actually very quickly it sort of
it came right back again and recovered
everything this was at 503 by
um what time is it right here 5 18 so 15
minutes later we recovered
that pullback okay so everyone's oh buy
the dip well a lot of times you get
those big moves like that you don't get
much of a dip what I like to see is you
get that big pump up Let the market sort
of breathe let the Traders reassess
what's going on you know this is five in
the morning in the US it's a Chicago
time on my chart so it's it's coming up
on lunchtime in the UK already
um so it's nice to see the market just
recover very quickly now
once it recovers after that big pump we
start making new highs and the volumes
right I just said a hundred contracts in
the gold on a one minute chart
at a price is Big volume and we see a
strong bid coming in here 223 so I know
already I've got a strong buyer now this
was after that pump right that got all
the way up to 3310 sold off we're coming
back now we're seeing big volumes coming
in on the bid side obviously above that
high of that pump which was down here at
33.10 so you know this one's coming in
at 35.70.
okay rally up to new highs
come off again okay fine going sideways
is this the high is this going to be the
high of the day or not nobody knows yet
right just watch the order flow sort of
going sideways you don't get you know
it's mostly negative Deltas in here
minus 138 minus 70 84 minus 86. I'm
going to get some small Deltas in here
you know five four nine Twenty One
Eleven four
you know minus 18 on this green candle
and we're just sort of going sideways
drifting sideways and then eventually
again we get all the way down to you
know 34 60 push down even a little bit
lower back down to 31.
getting down here in the 30s but as we
start coming back up
right watch the volumes remember our
high is up here at the
39.80 okay there's not a lot of volume
going through it's it's 7 A.M now
Chicago time
volumes are you know just average right
and you can see you know 25
50 60 15 contracts you know it's nothing
to get too excited about I mean you did
have that one big order that one big bid
earlier
at you know is it 35.70 and
then volume is has just been pretty much
steady now it starts taking out these
new highs and as we take out these new
highs making new highs again you see
another big volume in here 194. okay I
had a big volume earlier
didn't really do much you know it did
give some support to the market in the
near term Market went up a few dollars
but then sort of came off it went
sideways for the next two hours but
as we start trading in here as we're
taking out these highs you see the 194
here the 151
uh they're doing a little bit later
starting to see some more volume again
this is average volume as you're going
sideways boom take out a new height
another big volume in here 145.
okay
so watch these big volumes 101 as you're
making these new highs even here you got
138 as you're making new highs you have
strong bids coming in it's not just
taking out the highs and having the
offers get lifted right as the markets
move up
you're going to see aggressive buying
right you're going to see the offer get
taken out and then the next offer and
the next offer but what gives a market
legs so to speak is the big bids coming
in to support the market
now it's not always you're not always
going to get the big bid come in and
that's just going to put the base in
right but I know that I've got strong
buyers here so you know from eight
o'clock in the morning
you know 138 140 you know here's 101
here's 112 right I'm not at this point
I'm not so concerned with what's trading
on the offer because you know we're at
new highs of the day so I'm not
surprised to see strong volumes on the
offer but when I see strong volumes on
the bid it's telling me that not only
are Traders chasing this market up but
they're coming in and also bidding this
market up
okay what's more important the bidding
or the taking out the offers well you
know I don't want to say one is more
important than the other
because when you start taking out offers
bids start coming in and filling in uh
the bids right the previous offers are
going to become your bid but when you
see it come in for big size then you
know there's more to this move than
meets the eye you know it's a strong
move in the direction so again you know
138 146
um you know 112 is that 101 there and we
just keep going higher so it's Market is
going up with a strong bids coming in to
help you know prop up this Market I
don't say prop up because you know that
that's sort of the the wrong term in the
sense that you're thinking oh it can't
go any lower
but I know that I've got strong buyers
coming in here they don't want to just
start indiscriminately lifting the
offers
they're happy to work bids and absorb
whatever selling comes into the market
to help keep the market from going any
further okay so I got 112 111 right
get all the way up to 55 and a half
start coming off a little bit you know
you got this nice stacked buying and
balance see just sort of comes in here
now there was
strong offer here 101 okay again Market
had rallied all the way up to 55.90
again 55.90 from 25 right so we rallied
25 25 move in the gold you know this is
a good move normally
so we hit 55.90 start coming off again
you see some offers in here you know the
149 obviously the uh 101 here and then
look
next bar 102.
okay now I'm not saying that this is
related to this but again you know up
here at highs obviously people that were
buying it on the way up you know they're
happy to take profits as the market you
know sort of looks like it may have
peaked out for now because it was a big
move it's a 25 move up to this point and
it's starting to come off of it here
okay so maybe they're taking some money
off the table but then boom it comes
right back with the strong buying 102
right another 102 up here took out this
high up here was what 100 uh
60 contracts okay fine I mean we're at a
new high the fact that I just got right
through it pretty easily is a good sign
and then 140 again right here 149 so you
know as we're taking out these highs
you're seeing strong bids come into the
market you're not just taking out the
strong offers that's one thing that's
one side of the equation
people taking out the offers what you
want to see also is strong bids in there
to absorb you know this 102 here this
149. these guys are absorbing whatever
selling is coming into the market to
help keep it from dropping further
there's 102 here's 103 here's 149.
right and the market pops all the way up
straight up to 60. now again sort of to
discuss a little bit further on you know
yesterday's discussion on trap Traders
you know or stops being triggered this
is what stop looks like getting
triggered right up here new highs
all zeros big stack buying and balance
there came off you know the high was
59.40 we got down to uh
58.80 then the next bar continued up
okay that's what you like to see right
you can see stacked buying a balance
although this one's probably triggered
by a stop you know it gives you a decent
trade as long as it keeps going up you
go with it right if it fades if it
starts going the other direction you go
against it now here this is what we call
an inverse imbalance so you got this
Market again made new highs up here 62
1662.
it probably trigger to stop somewhere up
here around one and a half boom filled
it up it immediately came down that's
why we have this red line drawn you know
this is just telling us hey you know
what
what got triggered up here is probably a
stop and you should probably want to be
trading against it
right you see it came off a bit from the
60 area down into 57.90 eventually sort
of worked its way back up and
made that new high then finally started
coming off you know you're seeing some
strong
um selling coming here with the
imbalances in these bars but again you
know understand the markets
and that you're trading right you
understand what strong volume is for
that market and where it's appearing in
the market
now with gold again I know I've watched
gold for decades and I know that if I'm
looking at a one minute chart this is
what it normally looks like 19 2018.
um you know maybe you get some bars you
know some prices at 50s but you know
when I see 102 okay this is big and it's
not uncommon to see big volume come in
at a price but then I see 102 103 149
right I start seeing a lot of volume
coming in on the bid on a market that's
moving up in a short period of time it's
telling me that there's
bidders in the market okay there's
strong strong buyers appearing in the
market sorry about that
um to help support the market because
that's what you really want to see on a
move that's going up right if you're
looking at a normal your part chart
right you don't see that there's strong
support to keep this market up from keep
it from
dropping back down to where it was
so if you have the buyers coming in not
just lifting the offers but if you see a
strong bids coming in here strong bids
coming in here strong bids coming in
here you know that's something that you
can use to your advantage if you're just
looking at you know the normal bar chart
like this you're not seeing any volume
you're not seeing oh you know what I see
strong bids coming in here you're not
all you've seen is on on a Candlestick
chart you seem to open the high the low
of the clothes and obviously depending
on the color of the candle
either it's an up candle or a down
candle okay it's not giving you anything
else other than that but by looking at
the footprint yeah you can see where
that strong volume is coming in
and if it's coming in
at new highs
at new Highs at new highs you could feel
comfortable buying the highs you know
buying the highs is not something that
everybody likes to do right because
eventually the high is going to be put
in but if you have a reason to buy the
high then great
so anyway guys I hope you enjoyed this
video hope some of it made sense to you
be sure to uh
to subscribe to my channel you know so
you'll be alerted when the new videos
get out there and you know if you like
the video give it a thumbs up thanks
everyone bye bye